-Looking sharp, bud.
Thanks so much
for coming back to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-You know, we had Kate McKinnon
out here just now.
-I know.
-Yeah, and I was like,
"Well, maybe they know
each other."
We like to see
if our guests know each other.
-We have quite a history.
[ Laughter ]
-You certainly do.
This is a picture of you.
You met at the
Independent Spirit Awards.
Is that correct?
-This is our first time meeting.
-[Both] Yeah.
-And this is a picture
of Kate coming by you.
This is during her monologue,
maybe, or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
That's a mouthful of ham.
[ Laughter ]
Remember that.
-She has ham in her mouth?
She has ham in her mouth
and then this happened.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
-Yeah. Ahem.
-Wow.
Yeah.
The reason she's not out here
is, that night,
we promised each other
we would never see
each other again
[ Laughter ]
because we knew
we would destroy
each other's lives.
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Wow, that's getting to know
someone right there, Paul.
-I miss the simpler days,
when you could just
kiss a stranger
with a mouth full of him.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
-Thank you.
Not the first time I heard that.
Yeah, right. Yeah.
-Hasn't flown the past
couple of years, yeah.
-Pal, I saw "The Batman"
the other night
and you are fantastic
-Thank you.
in this as The Riddler.
The reviews are great,
by the way.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Great reviews.
-Thanks.
-I knew you were going
to nail it.
But how did this come about?
Did you kind of petition
for this or they wanted you?
-No, I actually didn't know much
about it
and I got a weekend phone call,
which is always sort of good
or bad news,
you know, the weekend phone
call from work.
And I was actually backing
out of a driveway
with my wife next to me
and my dad in the back seat.
And the call came up
on Bluetooth.
It was my agent
and I was like,
"I'm not going to get this.
It's the weekend."
And Zoe was like,
"Pick up the phone."
Pick up the phone
and it's like, you know,
"Matt Reeves wants
to talk to you
about playing The Riddler
and it looks," you know --
And when I hear good news,
I kind of just shut down.
I was like, "Okay. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay."
So I hung up the phone
and Zoe's like,
"Oh, my God.
What happened?
Like, what's wrong?"
You know, and I was like,
'I think they want me
to play The Riddler."
And she started freaking out
and I was freaking out.
My dad's in the back seat
and he's like,
"What's so exciting up there?"
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't want to tell him
because it wasn't totally
in the bag yet,
but also my dad has me
on like Google alert.
He calls his friends
about stuff.
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't want him to be like
the leak, you know...
[ Laughter ]
...before it was all good.
-So you had to lie to your dad?
-I had to lie to my dad.
But we had this
two-hour car ride,
where, the whole time,
Zoe and I are going like,
"[Bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
And my dad's, "What's going on?"
And then I knew, when we got
back to my parents' house --
we were visiting --
he was trying
to figure it out online
[ Laughter ]
and he couldn't.
-And then like a week later,
I could tell him, but, yeah.
-Well, here's a picture of you
as The Riddler and this is --
look at how frightening this is.
[ Cheering and oohs ]
-[Both] Yeah.
When did you find out
you weren't going to be
a Riddler that wore like
an outfit
with question marks on it?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, my agent,
who's backstage,
just reminded me that the first
thing I said to him
after I read the script was,
"There ain't any green spandex
in this one."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, no.
This is dark.
-Yeah, no.
The first time I read
the script, I mean, Matt Reeves,
it is a completely singular
vision he's got for this thing.
I was totally blown away
by the script, which, frankly,
I wasn't expecting to be.
Given that it's
a superhero film,
there are so many,
I felt so lucky like
I get to do this one because I
thought it was so good
and it's an interesting take
on the character.
-Yeah, it's dark.
Did you get to bring any
of your own ideas to this?
-Yeah, sure.
-Was the mask your thing?
-Yeah, okay, so there's
kind of like
a vigilante thing here, right?
Maybe my character doesn't
quite have the same resources
as, say,
another vigilante and so
[ Laughter ]
it's kind of more
of a home grown costume.
and I wanted --
-It's a very interesting
take, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, so I wanted like.
He still needs to be able to go
out in the day,
a la Bruce Wayne, right?
So I couldn't shave all the hair
off my body for like DNA.
I wanted the details covered.
He's super meticulous.
So I had this idea
of like wrapping myself in --
I have to call it cling wrap
because I think the Saran people
don't want
[ Laughter ]
any legal association
with my Riddler.
[ Laughter ]
I wrapped myself in cling wrap,
which kind of looks scary,
you know, with the light.
And I thought, "Okay,
now I'm not going to shed
any hairs here
on these crime scenes."
And then, the first day
of filming, about an hour in,
I just start to see white
and colors and my brain is --
things are getting very --
And it's day one,
so you don't want to be the
actor who's like...
-Complaining?
-...yeah, "I've got a little
headache here,
a little problem," you know.
-Sweating?
-You kind of suck it up.
You know, you can't sweat.
That's the issue.
It's like going back
inside of you.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so clingy.
-It's so sealed.
So I made it through day one
without telling anybody
that I was like --
and I got home that night
and I'm probably Googling
"brain swelling" in my bed
[ Laughter ]
and I'm like,
"Okay, is this a problem?"
And then, you know.
Or I was like,
"Is this the character?
Oh, my God,
this is going to be
a long shoot," you know?
-Yeah, exactly.
-And then the next day,
we just started to poke
some holes in the cling wrap.
My head could breathe.
Things got a little better.
And I might as well take
this opportunity
to offer a disclaimer
to any Halloween costumers
or cosplay fans out there --
maybe skip the cling wrap.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't need to do
the cling wrap
to be your Riddler.
-Yeah.
It's amazing,
your transformation
and how you do this guy
because he's creepy, man,
and it's scary
and it's frightening.
And I go, "Oh,
this is how he's playing this,"
and I go,
"This is a dark Batman."
But the idea is that
it's Batman's only second year
being the Batman.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And so the cops don't really
know if they can trust him.
The public doesn't know
if they can trust.
-And it also kind of turns
morality on its head.
So, yeah, it's like
an immersive action spectacle
that's also
a serial killer mystery,
psychological thriller,
horror film.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
You got to go see it
on the biggest screen you can.
I think it's --
I really like it.
-It's beautifully shot
and it's so well done, bud.
And this is the scene
I really wanted to show
-Great.
-because this is just Paul Dano
at his best, showing you how
to do it, man. I love it.
Here's Paul Dano
in "The Batman."
Take a look at this.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Rain falling ]
♪♪
[ Indistinct voice on TV ]
[ Door opens ]
-Police!
Hands up!
-Ah-choo!
♪♪
-He said, put your
[audio drop] hands up,
you son of a [audio drop].
♪♪
[ Stool creaking ]
[ Creaking ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Paul Dano, everybody.
"The Batman" is in theaters
and IMAX this Friday.